[Musique]
l'euthanasie tout le monde en talent
c'est un mot horrible
il n'y a pas de bonne mort il faut
alléger les souffrances les gens le
savent bien
ils essayent d'alléger les souffrances
et j'utilise des cocktails des mélanges
de drogue qui sont finalement peu
efficace alors pourquoi ne pas être
honnête
et pourquoi ne pas dire du moment où
vous voulez soulager un malade
et bien voilà la recette pour le
soulager vraiment et si vous avez le
courage de le faire et si le malade vous
le demande
alors voilà la bonne recette pourquoi
pas il ya un côté provocateur dans cette
histoire et ben c'est vrai je suis
provocateur de la vie dans ce cas là et
fils provocateur contre ce qui laisse à
côté d'eux des malades en promenant une
existence qui demeure la leur pendant
des malades agonise sur des lits
d'hôpital
[Musique]